Dayna alright one of my recommendations  is people try to take a road trip to  Shanksville Pennsylvania so that they  could see the flight 93 memorial there's  an additional reason the colleges of the  Washington and Jefferson College excuse  me they became partners with the  memorial and they have created an  exhibit talking about how important  baseball is in times of national tragedy  and one of the examples they have here  is after 9/11 so there's the baseball  that george w bush threw out at yankee  stadium you can also see the former a  New York City Mayor Rudy Giuliani's  windbreaker that he wore and I think we  have a picture here of the Washington  and Jefferson College students their  assistant history professor is David  Kiernan he helped create the exhibit for  the memorial and if you can try to get  there